[Music]
I'm here with Ella ASA and Finley from
miss Peregrine's Home for peculiar
children now I absolutely adored this
book the main thing that I noticed was
actually that Emma and olives
peculiarity the fire and the kind of
antigravity right in there have been a
switched around so I was wondering all
of you not just you how do you feel this
actually made a difference for the film
and how was it actually acting with that
difference you know a sort of strange
because I like both versions very much
so like the Emma and the book is fiery
but I mean I'm quite a compliment you're
here I mean the way Ella perceived
Emma's being late and flirty and I
really enjoyed that as a different
character was that was different in the
screenplay but I couldn't really choose
between them yeah because at first I was
like no Emma with fire that's way better
than I mean it's way way better you know
but as time went on I was like it's
quite a good character I can see within
the blonde and yes how do you feel do
you feel it kind of added to the film to
make it a bit more unique to the book I
think so I think it's really interest
but it's a really interesting image and
it's kind of original because we've look
we've always seen people with fire
powers that's a that's been around for a
while we never really see someone
floating on the end of a rope or walking
around with huge lead shoes yeah we're
awesome shoes that's right absolute
injustice if something different and you
kept the fiery personality which I
thought was brilliant thank you thank
you I had um yeah I was cows quite when
I first found out that's when everybody
wants to play that badass don't they
like those plays of the fire energy like
come at me yeah um actually I have to
say I enjoy its first of all the process
of making an entirely new character that
wasn't based on the book so I just had
the script sort of to learn from the
script and second of all to adapt a book
to a movie is incredibly difficult
you'll know that then there's never the
same you'll know that as well but I
think that it's almost a compliment to
the book that nobody's tried to exactly
replicate everything
things have been changed for cinematic
purposes and and actually when you see
it visually on screen it's so lovely
personally for an actor standpoint as
well it gives me a bigger storyline
because she's already fiery what could
she realize about herself you know she's
already confident she's already brave
but sadly to start off a little bit
heartbroken a little bit down and then
to sort of realize your own strengthen
to get over those trust issues and to
learn you can love again and you are
strong and you are brave I mean that
that's kind of journey that I'd like to
that I wanted to play and I wanted to
show a cross on screen and also just I
know people were bummed out about it I
know some of the book fans you know
unhappy but trust in Tim you know I know
not a single person in this process was
against it I think everybody was well up
for and I think you need to see the film
and yeah and and just take it as an
adaption of the book not an exact
replica that was a brilliant answer
thank you very much I also want to talk
about the whole superpowers supernatural
abilities everyone loves that it's been
done over and over see Marvel DC what's
so great about this though is that
they're quite dark and quite abnormal
maybe not things you would wish for as a
child one in particular is Enoch you're
pretty much like a little dr.
Frankenstein yeah so i was wondering
with all of you actually if you had
Enochs power of bringing people back to
life just for a little little moments
what famous person would you bring back
and why Bob Marley sorry I realized his
name's not just Bob and no I would
really enjoy to bring back an old
musician you know the kid play just just
to hear someone like Bob Marley life
would mean a lot to me or even even
Elvis Presley even though only played a
few chords just someone who is just
really iconic and yeah oh I agree we
don't agree with magicians I mean
alright this hot to pick Bob Marley was
a great price eighty-one House
well yeah this is making me depressed oh
man Tara some some amazing actors and
actresses who have Marilyn yes classic
uh Christopher we have another chat with
him would be cool I got to work with her
months
yeah it's cool guy that's cool yeah be
missed
oh he played the King all right and then
okay last question so you probably asked
a thousand times but out of all the
people which peculiarity would you want
the most you might not want any of them
but you have to choose thank you
Oh could you stop I'm so stunned to fire
okay thank you going yeah um
well I'm gonna agree I think Hugh's got
the coolest power and kind of the mom no
I wish little me what do you think the
rules in my opinion as well and I want I
want to see her copy to Hughes thanks
don't be too he's it's a receptive if it
wasn't if it wasn't you it would be
Millard minute well those boys are
Lawson pretty actually be naked all the
time
yes no I would see those hours train
train alright thank you very much guys
it's been about thank you choose stop
nicking my answers I didn't make it you
knew I was gonna go for you and now
that's what you know is going to go to
work here